sans jolie n'est ce pas bonjour vous
étiez là vous tombez bien aujourd'hui
c'est la saint casimir eu et c'est la
fête de casimir et moi je vais acheter
un joli cadeau regardez c'est bien non
pour ça je suis sûr que ça lui fera une
bonne surprise
des affiches c'est la saint casimir
c'est marseille eh ben ça alors comme
surpris je crois que c'est plutôt raté
tu sais qu'aujourd'hui c'est la saint
casimir je les regarde et on est sûr je
vois que je ne la prends à personne oui
et surtout pas quasi mai ah bon parce
que tu crois que c'est lui quelques
essais afic
enfin juline n'importe qui toi moi moi
les enfants qui est capable d'écrire
c'est la saint casimir
mais seuls casini a été capable d'écrire
c'est ma fait appel ce widget pas penser
et dire que je lui avait réservé une
surprise
un joli cadeau en oui lequel gérard
gelas encore au défi les membres de
partout j'ai trouvé chez un brocanteur à
vieux livres de cuisine qui indique la
recette du gloubiboulga ou le
gloubiboulga traditionnel oui formidable
alors écoutez bien écouter les enfants
écouter dans une grande assiette ou un
récipient mettre une banane dont on aura
au préalable enlever la peau la couper
en rondelles
râpez finement si carré de chocolat au
lait puis 50 grammes ou de cuillère de
confiture de fraise écrasée doucement le
tout en mélangeant bien et puis un petit
additifs pour les casimir us a ajouté 20
g de l'outarde est une saucisse de
toulouse cru mais tiède au met mais
c'est très intéressant ce n'est jamais
casimir ne m'avait dit que seuls les
casimir us mettait de la moutarde et de
la saucisse de toulouse cru mais tu y es
tu
et voilà
et le livre de cuisine mentionne que si
on met seulement la confiture de fraises
le chocolat et la banane ça s'appelle le
gloubiboulga des enfants je dis moi j'ai
bien envie de me faire un gloubi boulga
comme les enfants et vous tord il a dit
moi france avait tué un portelois
regarde une magnifique paire de ciseaux
a coupé le caoutchouc
c'est très originaire comme cadeau mais
à quoi s'en servir à tirer on july met
et pour confectionner son dessert favori
il prendra à la paire de ciseaux il
découpera en petit confetti ses morceaux
de chambres à air et il mélangera le
tout avec sa crème chantilly
c'est une excellente idée je suis sûre
que celle ravira certainement
bonjour mes très chers amis bonjour à ma
télé vous comme ça pour tout vous dire
je suis fâché je croyais être le seul et
le premier avant penser à l'instinct
kazimi veut dire que casimir a vraiment
été le tout premier choix mais je trouve
ça particulièrement agaçant nous détendu
vous donnez moi votre verre au monsieur
monsieur du snob mais pour être plus
calme quelques mouvements de gymnastique
actifs bcv pressez vous baissez vous
m'avez vous voilà et c'est vous
devez-vous et prend l'air mais prend
lève sur les côtés j'ai connu des petits
ciseaux de laptops un peu de course à
pied en direction du bain en petites
foulées est bonne à olhao la tête me
tour santé bien-être ou la tête me
tourne mon verre oui mon bon avec vous
inquiétez pas monsieur du snop jolie mis
dans la poubelle et il s'alliera plus le
jardin dans la poubelle mais c'est ma
dernière génial sculpture pour la fête
de casimir hayon excusez moi monsieur 19
regarder et il n'est pas du tout à biner
merci il ne nous reste plus qu'à
attendre quasiment oui j'ai
malheureusement avec toutes ces
pancartes nos surprises ne seront plus
des survols écouter métiers du snow béni
je crois que nous devons quand même
réservé à casimir une bonne petite
surprise
il verra
[Musique]
bonjour mes amis vous avez mikado quel
cadeau mongauzy mais quoi devrions-nous
temps fait mais il n'y a aucune raison
enfin c'est ma fête à saint casimir
mais franchement casimir c'est ce que je
croyais avant d'avoir vu les ponts car
comment mais c'est parce que c'est moi
qui les ai posé pour vous rappeler que
c'était ma feinte alors casimir
regardez les ce n'est pas ce qui est
écrit un s'éteindre à saint-casimir
sahara vous avez voulu me faire une
farce mais fait pourquoi dis-tu ce parce
que vous avez rajouté le mot pas sur les
pancartes
pourquoi n'es tu si sûr mais enfin parce
que moi à casimir je n'aurais jamais
fait une faute de francs c'est pareil on
ne dit pas c'est pas la saint casimir
mais ce n'est pas la saint casimir
je sais que c'est incroyable à un mot
kazimiyah retenir
tu as bien méritée tk2 bonne
[Musique]
à